JASON SILVA: I still
like to believe
that that's actually a myth.
JAMIE WHEAL: Which?
JASON SILVA: That people
don't actually die.
[LAUGHS]
That we actually won't.
It's something that
happens to other people.
You know what I mean?
JAMIE WHEAL: I think that is
the great mellowing of life,
isn't it?
JASON SILVA: So on "Shots
of Awe," one of the things
that we try to do is
summarise these kind
of ecstatic realizations.
I stumble upon
something fascinating,
and I want to explain it, and
share it, and kind of hold it
in stasis.
And this guy right here,
my friend Jamie Wheal,
is the co-founder the
Flow Genome Project.
And Jamie, you did a TEDx talk
called "From Altered States
to Altered Traits." and it's all
about hacking the flow state.
You are also
creating a flow Dojo,
which is helping people reverse
engineer their flow states,
and create these ecstatic states
of mind in which people perform
their best and feel their best.
So tell us about some of
these tools and techniques
that you're implementing in the
flow Dojo with Steven Kotler.
What are you guys doing?
JAMIE WHEAL: Sure, well,
what we're teeing up
is the world's first
research and training
facility dedicated to
ultimate human performance,
or flow states.
And the premise is
what would happen
if we took the hands-on science
museum like the Exploratorium
here in San Francisco, with all
the sort of kinetic exhibits
the kids get to monkey with
and learn about bigger forces,
and apply it to,
basically, kinetics--
our bodies-- and
sort of this notion
that as we train our bodies
and brains to work really well
together, then our
waking cells get
to experience more accurate
information processing, greater
resourcefulness and
emotional resilience,
and generally amplify pattern
recognition, perspective
holding, and, therefore, more
increasingly sophisticated
and accurate decision making.
JASON SILVA: Flow states--
you feel your best
and you perform your best.
Elite athletes when they're in
the zone, jazz musicians when
they just literally go crazy
and they're just improvising,
channeling almost.
Now, these states
are associated with
these brief,
transitory instances
that we get to peek at Nirvana.
But what you're saying is
that now, through advances
in technology,
psychology, neurobiology,
and pharmacology--
drugs, right-- we now
have the capacity to back-door
access these flow states,
so that they're not haphazard,
fleeting, ephemeral states,
bu that they become part
of the human experience
on a daily basis.
JAMIE WHEAL: Yeah, for sure.
And so that's the
reverse engineer part.
JASON SILVA: OK
JAMIE WHEAL: So in
the past, how we
would experience it would
be I seeking a flow state.
I might be lucky, have one
by dumb luck or design.
But either way, I'd have it.
And it would come and go.
And then I'd come back to me.
JASON SILVA: Right.
JAMIE WHEAL: Right.
JASON SILVA: Easier than ever
to get high, as hard as it's
always been to stay that way.
JAMIE WHEAL: Yeah,
the perennial ennui.
Curses, back here again.
JASON SILVA: Brief dopamine
hit, back here again.
I've orgasmed and now it's over.
JAMIE WHEAL: What a moment
of clarity and regret
that is for so many.
JASON SILVA: Clarity,
regret and despair.
JAMIE WHEAL: But like
the evolutionary impulses
cease to intoxicate me and
hijack my motor skills.
JASON SILVA: I cannot
stabilize ecstasy.
The goosebumps are gone
as quickly as they can.
But you're talking
about literally
creating the conditions
where you could just
keep surfing that wave.
Aren't we acting
almost Promethean?
I mean your own work
with Steven Kotler talks
about stealing fire.
Like, are human beings prepared?
Should they be allowed to
know the secret songs that
orchestrate the universe
of the neurochemistry
of lived experience?
Do we get to tweak and
upgrade subjectivity?
Because that's what you're
talking about, right?
JAMIE WHEAL: Tweaking and
upgrading subjectivity,
yeah, I would say, and
add a multi perspectival
in front of that
subjectivity, and I
think you're off to the races.
JASON SILVA: And
so how do we do it?
Flow Dojo-- you design
spaces that design us back.
I mean, we're talking
ontological design.
We're talking harnessing
feedback loops to change
behavior and change patterns.
JAMIE WHEAL: Yeah, I mean,
basically just think of it
sort of the training center
for creating, like, Iron Man.
Like imagine if a future
sort of Tony Stark was like,
OK, I'm going to put together
the best technologies
to hyper train or
hyper condition
my physical capacities,
cognitive skills,
visionary tracking.
You just take
physical fitness out
of the kind of beach muscles,
cosmetic and aesthetic,
and you turn it into
athletic and neurokinetic.
So you've just completely just
rebooted physical culture.
And actually, is more of a
throwback to 19th century
Germany and the
Gymnasium effect, which
is a throwback to Plato
and the original Academy
and Pythagoras, and
that whole crew.
So there's this beautiful
Western tradition
of radically embodied cognition,
philosophy, celebration,
the symposium,
drinking together,
all of it-- celebration,
wine, women, and song.
It became the Aquarian, sex,
drugs, and rock and roll.
And so we go along.
And here we are.
JASON SILVA: And so we go on.
We may contribute a
verse and all that jazz.
JAMIE WHEAL: Sure.
JASON SILVA: Yes, this
gets me really excited.
Now one of the things he
talked about in your TEDx talk
was how technology
is allowing us
to pump dual awareness
through satellite dishes
into iPhones, beaming brains.
And you talked about
that trajectory.
You talked about
Bob Dylan playing
a small, little concert,
and then plugging
in his Stratocaster
and beaming electrified
musical expression
into 100,000 minds.
I'm paraphrasing, but talk
about the role of technology
in allowing us to literally
radically extend these insights
and transformations, to
mediate and tweet consciousness
with tools and technologies.
JAMIE WHEAL: Well, I think I
think you pretty well said it.
I mean, it's that sense
that we are able to shape
and prime our environments and
our psychosomatic experiences.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
JAMIE WHEAL: So with
music-- with deep,
thumping bass and incredibly
high image amplified,
so different directional
sound, projection mapping
of incredible high definition,
resolution and ridiculous--
especially when synchronized
with music and beat.
You start dislocating all of
our geospatial or proprioceptive
reference points.
So I'm not even sure
what I'm looking at.
Where did the horizon line go?
What's happening here?
JASON SILVA: And it doesn't
even matter, because you're just
rolling with bliss.
JAMIE WHEAL: Well, those things,
and then you do the syncopation
and the different
beats per minute, which
also entrain bodily features.
It's that old-- it
wasn't Johannes Kepler.
It was one of those early
watch makers who, remember,
discovered that
the pendulums all
would synchronize in his
clock shop, his watch shop.
And what he realized is
they all synchronized
to the rate of the
largest pendulum.
So there's this coherence
effect around waveforms.
JASON SILVA: OK, and
we're harnessing that.
We're exploiting that for our
own gain, for our own bliss.
JAMIE WHEAL: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: I like that.
I mean, we've always used
tools and technologies
to create bliss.
I mean, we use language
to write poetry.
We use musical instruments
to create melodies
that act as wallpapers
for our minds,
to use your term
from last night.
But what new forms of human
beauty and human subjectivity
will become possible as
we create a new generation
of mind-melding technologies?
New drugs-- I mean, now we're
seeing a renaissance in America
with the use of psychedelics
being more widely
acceptable as psychotherapeutic
tools for people with PTSD.
But the article in
"The New Yorker,"
written by Michael Pollan,
talked about the idea
of making well people better.
So we can actually create a
new generation of smart drugs
and mind-altering chemicals,
both internal ones
and external ones that we can
use to make well people better.
That it's not just about
fixing an affliction,
but it's about expanding what
it means to be, and perceive,
and be human.
You know, I keep coming
back to this idea
that human beings-- you
know, we're getting better.
We're looking up
the skirt of Nature,
looking under the hood
of our own brains.
And we're getting
increasingly better
at mapping these ecstatic
states, these flow states.
And we're getting
increasingly better
at mediating these
ecstatic states, right?
So I want you to talk
to me about the poetry
of these ecstatic states,
in the sense that, like,
of course we want
to mediate ecstasy,
because ecstasy is the most
beautiful thing in the world.
It's standing at the
playa of Burning Man,
or going into an iMax
theater and listening
to some beautiful Hans Zimmer
score that moves you to tears,
or the Grateful Dead concert you
were talking about yesterday.
[LAUGHS]
Remember when you were
talking about that,
the band is going
to play with Phish?
Talk to me about that
place, why we go there,
and why it's good
to want to go there,
the nobility of what
Flow Genome is doing.
JAMIE WHEAL: Well,
I mean, I would
say what we are hoping to do
is to start a conversation,
and build a community
of people of like minds
that are passionate as
well about the upper limits
of human possibility.
JASON SILVA: The upper limits
of human possibility-- I mean,
one of the things that you guys
are going to talk about, you
and Steven Kotler
in your new book,
is the altered states economy.
JAMIE WHEAL: For sure.
JASON SILVA: OK, the fact
that people spend upwards
of billions, trillions
of dollars to alter
their consciousness,
to feel good, $20,
gimme an Indiana
Jones thrill ride.
Here's $100.
Send me to a dream within
a dream in "Inception."
Here is $100.
Take me to "The
Never-Ending Story."
There's something we're willing
to pay for and labor for.
And so you're saying we barely
have glimpsed what's possible.
You're probing the contours
of the upper limits
of human experience.
I just want you to tell
me about that dance.
I love what you guys are doing.
I want to turn my
colander into a chalice.
I want to mediate my ecstasy.
I want-- I want everybody to
be able to experience that.
So what we need to do?
What's missing?
Where are we on that
trajectory right now?
JAMIE WHEAL: Yeah, I think we're
right there with all the parts
and puzzle pieces.
And as far as
literally and reliably
being able to put people into
as expansive and interesting
states of awareness as they can
manage, and at the same time,
that's not the fail point.
The fail point is
what it's always been,
which is you human discipline.
And so we get distracted.
And we get knocked off the path.
And we get bored.
And we get frustrated.
And we dabble, and we hack,
and we obsess, and we crash.
And that notion of we think
it should be endless peak
moments instead of the
plateaus of mastery practice
until the next one.
And you'll get an
integration, which often
happens in that theta state.
And in fact, theta,
depending on who's
research you're
following, gamma bursts,
those integrative Gestalt
ahas, the Eurekas,
can only occur in a
substrate of theta waves.
Right, so that's
one of the things.
JASON SILVA: Say that again.
Eureka moments can only what?
JAMIE WHEAL: So the
burst of gamma waves,
of neurologic activity, is
correlated with the Gestalt
integrative experience.
JASON SILVA: Seeing
the whole pattern.
JAMIE WHEAL: The
Eureka aha, I got it.
JASON SILVA: Aerial view,
big picture, Gestalt.
JAMIE WHEAL: Shazam.
JASON SILVA: Shazam.
JAMIE WHEAL: Right,
and that occurs only
on a substrate of
theta wave activity.
So that's where that particular
bolt of lightning goes.
So putting yourself into
a theta state on purpose
through respiratory regulation,
through any kind of neuro bio
feedback, through cardiac
controls and practices,
through any of those components,
you're then putting yourself--
you're like Ben Franklin
flying the kite with the key
in a storm.
You're right there
waiting for it to hit.
JASON SILVA: How often do
you get it in your own life?
JAMIE WHEAL: Goodness
gracious, I mean,
I feel like I am blessed with
getting to experience it as
often as I pay attention to it.
JASON SILVA: OK.
JAMIE WHEAL: Which varies.
JASON SILVA: That requires
a kind of priming, too.
You've got to be there.
You got to be present.
You've got to have the
cognitive resources to witness
and trigger those states.
JAMIE WHEAL: I mean,
yeah, and I think
ultimately, I think
my experience of it--
and maybe this is
just me, maybe I just
had this coming
in spades-- but I
have found that the
more time you spend
in those kind of effortless
effort conditions, the more
important is to have
your house in order.
So you sort of-- and
I don't-- I mean,
I have no presumptions whether
this is a universal truth
or just my experience.
But it seems like there's a
price for experiencing it.
And the price for
experiencing it
is acting on the information,
acting on the goodness, truth,
and beauty that you
apprehend while there,
and then trying to
live up your damnedest
to that example and inspiration
when we're back here.
And if you skip that step,
it's on your mortal soul
the next time you go
back to the wishing well.
[LAUGHS]